foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
he is being called the polygamist of the
century
in 2022 Arabic papers and TV reported on
a Saudi man who married 53 times in 43
years in an effort to find peace in his
life ostensibly the 63 year old man
called Abu Abdullah confirmed on Saudi
television that he did not look for
personal pleasure in his multiple
marriages but for stability and
emotional comfort
Abdullah got married for the first time
at the age of 20. his wife was six years
older than him he thought a more mature
woman would offer stability
but when they fought he married a second
wife
he pointed out that when a problem arose
between his first and his second wife he
thought the solution would be to marry a
third and a fourth wife
and after some time he divorced the
first and the second and the third wife
to satisfy the fourth wife and so the
soap opera continued for 43 years
you know in recent decades the number of
men married to more than one woman has
decreased in the Arab world but it is
still legal in 58 countries mostly
because the Koran specifically allows
for up to four wives
Abu Abdullah emphasized to the media
that he's now married to only one woman
and does not plan to marry again
yes we'll wait and see
you know it makes me think Pastor Cruz
about Solomon
it tells us in the Bible Solomon I don't
know that he's been beat by too many But
First Kings 11 verse 3 it says he had
700 wives and princesses and 300
concubines wow
but uh yeah all of that marrying and
divorcing is obviously not God's plan
and I should maybe say for our friends
that are watching right now I'd like to
welcome Pastor Aaron Cruz who is here
and he's one of our Associates at the
Granite Bay church where we pastor
Pastor Ross is on his way overseas right
now on a mission project and this is a
Pastor Aaron's second time first time
with me yeah for the first time uh
probably a few months ago I was with
Pastor Jean we had a blast I was helping
him out Fielding a few questions so I'm
happy to be here with you Pastor Doug
and I happen to answer your questions
you know and if his last name sounds
familiar it's because we've been giving
away his grandfather's books on this
program for 25 years now that's right uh
Pastor Aaron I think your real name is
technically Joseph is that right yes
it's uh now legally my middle name so I
am Joe Cruz for all of you at Joe Cruz
fans I am the grandson and inherited his
name to an extent
so I think that's really neat the way
the Lord worked all that out and we are
still giving away Joe Cruz books but
back to our subject about marriage and
by the way I was telling Pastor Cruz I
said I'm not picking on you because he's
getting married in a few weeks amen one
month just uh one month away my fiance
is actually here in the studio she won't
be making a a a a an appearance but uh
she is here to support me and I'm really
excited about that and I do not plan uh
Katie if you can hear me over there I do
not plan on having more than you as my
wife so amen yes I'll try to follow the
biblical model on that that's right and
we've got a scripture that talks about
that because I think we all know that uh
some countries not only do they have
multiple marriages but some people do it
by they get married then divorced and
then they remarry and then they divorce
and then they remarry and I was sharing
with our crew before the program my dad
was married five times and my mother was
married four times and wow that's
happens quite a bit in North America but
what did Jesus say Matthew 19 verse 4
and he answered and said to them have
you not read that he that made them at
the beginning male and female and he
said for this reason a man shall leave
his father and mother and be joined to
his wife and the two shall become one
flesh so then they're no longer one no
longer two but one flesh therefore what
God has joined together let not man
separate
and we get a lot of questions during our
broadcasts that have to do with marriage
and divorce and does a person have a
right to remarry and what are grounds
for divorce and we have a special offer
today we don't offer this often but it's
a book called what the Bible says about
marriage divorce and remarriage and
we're going to give that away free
tonight for those who would like to get
a copy of that
how do they do it yeah well you can
simply go to your if you have a cell
phone you can simply dial
pound250 and then say to your mobile
device Bible answers live that is
pound250 and then say Bible answers live
but if you don't have a cell phone and
you have just a regular phone some of us
still have those you can call
1-800-835-6747
amen well before we get to the phones
and our questions for tonight uh Pastor
Aaron you want to go ahead and have
prayer for us I would love to that's
Bower heads your heavenly father thank
you for this day of life that you have
given to us uh Lord I pray that you may
speak through us this evening as we
answer Bible questions with your answers
by God's grace uh fill us with your
spirit we pray in Jesus name amen amen
all right are you ready let's go to the
phone see what's coming up all right
well our first caller for this evening
is Joe calling in from Washington hello
Joe are you here what is your question
this evening
I am thank you um what a pleasure
um can you hear me loudly loud and clear
okay I have a friend uh and uh she's a
new friend and um I'm white and she is a
person of color and we talk about race a
lot because I'm married to a black man
so it opens the that door about the
mystery of racism and she told me that
her people believe that
um
God uh God struck them with
uh occurs
because of a sin she could she didn't
know what sin and that is why they have
spent centuries being
um abused and you know
yes I know exactly what you're talking
about I don't believe that but I do not
know where to go
I don't know where it came from from
well we're going to share with you if
you look in the Book of Genesis when
it's talking about Noah and I think you
might find this in Genesis 9 where it
says in verse 20 Noah became a farmer
and he planted a Vineyard and then he
drank the wine and was drunk and he
became uncovered in his tent he was kind
of stumbling around drunk and unclothed
and him the father of Canaan saw the
nakedness of his father and instead of
you know just covering his father up he
went out and I think he and his son
Kanan kind of laughed at their father
who had was stumbling around drunk in
the tent and was uncovered
and but Shem and japheth went and they
backed into the tent with a robe and
they covered them up and then Noah when
he sobers up he pronounces a curse on
him and there are those who have said
that the three sons of Noah created the
three races and that ham was black and
japheth was Asian and Shem was Caucasian
and there's no Bible truth to that I
think some people used that years ago to
try and endorse slavery and they you
know made a case that ham was the father
of all the African people
but you don't really have the Nations
dividing until you get to Genesis
chapter 11. and they basically got
together based on what languages they
could understand it had nothing to do
with the color of skin
so the races didn't really grow their uh
distinctions until the people did
separate and through the way genetics
work is through intermarriage over many
generations certain traits become
dominant so that was a myth that has
been perpetrated and some people I guess
still repeat it but it's it's absurd
it's not biblical
yeah uh good answer Pastor Doug and
another verse that kind of comes to my
mind is actually the second commandment
in Exodus 20 verse 5 it talks about I
the Lord your God I'm a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children to the third and
fourth generations of those who hate me
ham certainly committed a bad sin
against his father but there's no
evidence that that sin carried on the
consequences for hundreds of generations
hundreds and hundreds of generations
right that's just not something there
but uh hey thanks Joe so much for asking
that question next we have Ronald
calling in from Massachusetts hello
Ronald are you there what is your
question
hello pastors thank you for taking my
call can you hear me yes loud and clear
awesome so I have a few questions but
they told me to ask just one and the
most important for right now is about
this sabbath so I've been impressed on
by the Holy Spirit to start keeping the
Sabbath
and uh doing my research about this
Tapas I found that uh like I have family
in different countries where there are
many hours ahead of us so they're
already in Sabbath and we're behind but
then I also found that there's countries
that are
ah like a whole day ahead of us and
other countries that don't even have
Sunset certain times of the year
so they say that shipping Sabbath was
just for the national Israel back then
um just wondering how's the best way
with all of this evidence to explain
that we still have to keep the Sabbath
and that the Bible actually supports
all of us as mankind to keep the Sabbath
yeah well of course the Sabbath begins
and ends with sunset according to the
Bible on the seventh day of the week or
as the seventh day begins uh you keep
the Sabbath when it gets to you uh you
know if you're taking a plane around the
world when do you get on the plane well
when it lands and it's at your
destination it's interesting you would
mention that because as I speak right
now I'm here in California my wife has
gone ahead of me to Australia
and she was enjoying the Sabbath over
there before the Sabbath had come to me
because they're about a day ahead
so but I don't find any complication
with that and I always think it's
interesting this question comes up when
people learn the Sabbath truth because
folks don't have any problem getting to
church on Sunday
uh even though they're in different time
zones they go to church when the day
gets there
and so we keep the Sabbath when it comes
to US based on the sun and the time and
the days everybody in the world even the
North Pole we've got a seven day week
yeah so it yeah it's not not a problem
yeah Hey Ron Ronald thank you so much
for your question you know I might
mention to Ronald just one more thing
you know we have a website Ronald and
it's called
sabbathtruth.com it's one of the most
popular websites on the subject just
reams of information on the Sabbath if
you just go to sabbathtruth.com and for
our friends that are listening that
speak that are bilingual speak Spanish
it's also in Spanish it's samado
biblical dot com and uh just has a whole
Encyclopedia of questions and answers
including this one thanks so much for
your question yes all right our next
caller is calling in from Ohio and his
name is Glenn hello Glenn are you there
with us
yes I am thank you very much for taking
the call
you are welcome
go ahead thank you my question concerns
the feasts of Leviticus 23. people tell
me I'm about it that you know
those are not Jewish feasts God says
tell the children of Israel these are my
feasts and it's a capital m so we're
talking about peace of God
and the question I have about this is
there seems to be an allusion of some of
those people about the keeping of the
feasts whether they're whether they
should be or should not be or they're
not for Christians or a lot of different
faithful about whether they should be
kick or not and my question is should we
be keeping the peace in lieu of the
scripture that Zechariah
chapter 14
verses 16 through 19. does that have any
bearing on whether we should keep the
Feast of Tabernacles in this case or not
well tell you what let me do something
Lynn for the benefit of our friends that
are listening I'm going to read that
Zechariah 14. Judo also will fight at
Jerusalem and the wealth of all the
surrounding Nations shall be gathered
together Gold Silver and apparel and
great abundance such shall be the plague
on the horse and on the mule and on the
camel in that day
and uh I think I think you want to
especially go to verse 16. and it'll
come to pass everyone who has left of
all the nations which have come against
Jerusalem shall go up from year to year
and worship the king the Lord of hosts
to keep the Feast of Tabernacles
now the Feast of Tabernacles was their
memorial of their deliverance from
slavery
and we will be remembering that God has
saved us from the slavery of sin
um so I think this is just a a symbol of
uh of course when it's talking about
going up to Jerusalem it's talking about
the New Jerusalem we believe is in
heaven you can read in Isaiah chapter 66
where it says then from one new moon to
another and from one Sabbath to another
shall All Flesh come to worship before
the Lord so among those 52 sabbaths in a
year one will be a special way of
remembering our Redemption now I would
say to a person that if you want to keep
the feasts uh enjoy yourself Paul says
in Romans chapter 14 one man regards one
day above another another man regards
every day alike says if you're gonna
regard a day regard it to the Lord if
you're not going to regard the day to
the Lord you do not regard it he's
speaking specifically about the Jew the
feasts there and not the Sabbath of the
Ten Commandments which was part of God's
perfect plan the feast all came as a
result of sin the Sabbath of the Ten
Commandments was in the Garden of Eden
it goes back to the beginning
but we do have a book we can offer you a
free copy plan that talks about
the feasts and if you call amazing facts
call that Resource number and ask for
the booklet dealing with the feasts
yeah that's a great resource just a few
extra verses want to kind of throw in
there so there's a prophecy in Daniel
chapter 9 for telling the arrival of the
Messiah and there in Daniel chapter 9
verse 27 it says that the Messiah he
shall bring an end to sacrifice and
offering right foretelling that the
various cultic rituals that God himself
had established that were Shadows
pointing to himself were no longer uh be
kept in the same way that his people did
in the old Covenant Old Testament era
right so nowadays if it'd be impossible
to fulfill to the letter of the law uh
all of the various feasts you'd have to
go number one to enact to the temple in
Jerusalem which isn't there right you'd
have to bring an animal sacrifice which
New Testament makes quite clear those
were just Shadows of of the sacrifice of
Jesus so if you're going to insist on on
keeping some of these in the exact same
way of the Old Testament it's going to
be quite difficult and I don't think
it's something that the scripture
commands us to do explicitly any longer
yeah when Jesus died on the cross it
says the veil in the temple was torn
from top to bottom and this indicated
that the whole ceremonial system of
sacrifices and Feasts
and that's what it's talking about also
in Colossians yeah you know that's all
mailed to Colossians chapter two yeah
that's another good one well
thanks so much for your question Glenn
our next caller is Judith calling in
from Nevada
hello junith
hello Pastor Arun and Pastor dog can you
hear me yes very well okay
very well thank you for taking my call
anyway my question is uh about the uh
the deception of Eve around it to
achieve the knowledge of Good and Evil I
am not so convinced that they succeed
got deceived because of her curiosity I
um when it comes to my questions and
biblical
questions that pop up in my mind I
always see this spiritual side because
this is a spiritual book and that
cardinality cannot be applied in these
Divine spiritual book which is uh
presenting the infinite mind of this
loving God that we serve so can you
please give us an answer as to the
biblical perspective was it because of
the presence of the one-third of the
Angels it was deceived by the devil or
Satan was around the tree as well that
because
the devil got Eve into a conversation
they had a chance of devouring kind of
devouring in there that put her in a
cloudy state of mind with the
instruction of God was very very Crystal
Clear not to even touched not to eat of
the fruit of the food the knowledge of
Good and Evil all right so I was
thinking that
Eve was possessed here as the devil is
copy cutting the ways of Jesus himself
when Jesus is around well now is this a
question
yeah you gotta you gotta make it a
yeah so the
reason or the rationale why it was
deceived it was in fact the instruction
of God is so Crystal Clear okay well for
one thing how was Eve deceived so easily
uh you mentioned that well we know the
devil was there possessing the serpent
could he have other fallen angels that
were there that were whispering in her
ear possibly the Bible doesn't say but I
would also think that God's good good
angels that may have been trying to
encourage her to make the right decision
and his Spirit within here but uh
there's a few things at play here one is
the devil played upon the very things
that attracted him he said you will be
like God he was saying to Eve you know
you'll have special powers look I was
just a serpent and now I can talk liquid
eating the fruit did for me and you can
have this power on God's trying to keep
something from you and so that of course
got her curiosity the desire for more
power was attractive and also Eve had
never heard a lie before I know it's
hard for us to imagine living in a world
of Innocence where everyone tells the
truth
and she had to Grapple with the fact
that she was being deceived someone was
dating an outright lie or at least a
partial lie
he said has God said you shouldn't eat
from any of the trees well he
exaggerated that so all those things
were at Play Judith I think and um
yeah yeah a telling verse is found about
the deception that Paul writes in second
Corinthians chapter 11 and verse three
we get a little insight into the
deception of Eve
um it reads Paul writes he says but I
fear less somehow as the serpent
deceived Eve by his craftiness so your
minds may be corrupted from the
Simplicity that is in Christ and then he
says what the deception was for if he
who comes preaches another Jesus whom we
have not preached etc etc he says you
may well put up with it so what Satan
did to Eve is he presented to Eve
another version of who God is he made
God to look like an overbearing overly
restrictive God a liar someone who can't
be trusted and selfish he's afraid to
share power and he was hiding it exactly
so when a picture is presented of our
loving God to be this tyrannical view
well then Eve was presented with these
two pictures and she chose the wrong
picture and that caused her to Rebel
that's right
so Judith we do have a booklet that
talks about Temptation and we'll be
happy to send you or anybody that wants
uh have a free copy of that it's called
tips for resisting temptation and Pastor
Aaron how do they get that well you can
dial in if you have a cell phone to
pound two five zero that's pound two
five zero and simply
um uh say Bible answers live and there
you will uh ask the the person that
you'll speak to for the offer
um what was it again tips for resisting
tips for resisting temptation
very good okay I think we're ready for
the next call all right our next caller
is calling in from Illinois and it is
Gary hello Gary are you there
yes in the second Thessalonians 2 it
says Satan will appear and perform signs
powers and miracles that will deceive
all those who love Master truth are
those people who love not the truth the
same people who bring Believers before
Kings authorities and principalities in
Mark 13 where we're not to worry about
uh what we should say or premeditate but
words will be given to us I know are
those the same people who Deliver us to
Kings and authorities and is the
Antichrist giving giving all those who
love not the truth a new philosophy a
new doctrine that Christians will have
to answer to
okay well anybody who's rejecting the
the truth when God brings it through the
Holy Spirit and uh they're convicted and
they stifle that they would fall into
the category that they can come to the
place where they sincerely believe a lie
because they've rejected the truth when
you take away light the only thing left
is Darkness or it's nothing God is
trying to
trick them with a lie it's when you
reject truth the only thing left is a
lie and that would be the same group
that will bring us before Kings and
councils and God says in that hour the
holy spirit will tell you what you ought
to say in defense of the truth and we're
hoping that at those occasions there are
people listening who are still open
when Paul was being tried and a number
of occasions when Paul was being
persecuted and tried and in front of
different groups there were people in
the crowd listening to him again give a
faithful witness that were convicted and
later became believers I'm thinking
about sergius paulus who ended up being
believing even though bar Jesus was
resisting that the sorcerer was
resisting Paul's words
so yeah I think anybody rejecting the
truth Falls in that category yeah if
those who reject the truth it's all
throughout Biblical history that they
have a tendency to persecute God's
people and bring us before trials and
some will be sincere I mean Paul when he
was first persecuting Christians
he thought he was helping God out yeah
and he he just was wrong yeah yeah all
right we got maybe time for one more
before a break let's see all right our
next caller is calling in from Texas and
it's Jerry hello Jerry are you there
what is your question hi Aaron just a
side note yes I first saw you on TV two
weeks ago when I called your father
Larry he's been my friend for a few
years anyway my question is that uh
there's many verses in the Bible that
referred to this uh the verse I'm taking
now is first Samuel 4 4. and said so the
people sent the Shiloh and from there
They Carried the Ark of the covet of the
Lord of hosts who sits above the
cherubin and of course it says two sons
of uh Samuel but
is it possible that Jesus Christ was the
other guardian angel above the Throne of
God
I don't think so uh and part of the
reason is you have a more Vivid picture
of the the ark itself was just a
miniature depiction of God's throne in
heaven with the two angels when you look
in Isaiah chapter 6 he is in the
presence of God and it says there's
these two cherubim that are saying holy
holy holy
uh Jesus is the one to be worshiped and
so Jesus wouldn't be the angel on the
right or the left he's not an angel
Jesus is God the son and it says in
Hebrews the Angels worship Him
so if you think the two angels it
directed that both Solomon and Moses
that those angels would be faced towards
each other inward with their faces down
kind of like the picture in Isaiah and
it says they're covering their faces in
Isaiah because the presence of God is
there and uh their their attention is
focused on the one who's on the throne
which would be Christ and you know you
could also say the father because Jesus
you know he sits down and says at the
right hand of the father
but um that's a picture of God in the
middle yeah Jesus um I mean Revelation
chapter 3 he's Seated on the throne with
with God the father right he overcame
and seated at the right hand of the
Throne of God so so Jesus is definitely
there on the throne
um we don't know who the other Angel is
maybe some people speculate to a degree
maybe it's Gabriel right but the
ultimate thing is the Bible's not clear
exactly who the other Fallen Angel
excuse me the other unfallen Angel was
yeah it would be uh I think that one at
least is Gabriel some of my Catholic
friends say one of us a guy named
Raphael but I don't know where they did
that hey friends you can hear the music
we're going to take a break be back with
more Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at
aftv.org at
aftv.org you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
hi friends I think everybody knows that
there is a Health crisis in the country
it used to be years ago when people
worked on farms and got a lot more
physical activity that they'd eventually
get old they'd get sick and they'd die
but today what happens is people get
sick and spend 30 years dying because of
their poor living practices well amazing
facts is going to be bringing a program
to you that's going to teach you how you
can have a longer stronger more abundant
Optimum life and it's called The Amazing
Facts Health Summit it'll be at the
hilltop Church in Granite Bay February
24 and 25 you can also watch on Amazing
Facts television you can see it on
YouTube on our Facebook Channel but we'd
love to have you come in person we're
going to have some great speakers there
and it will change your life in fact I'm
feeling better already I feel more
healthy how about you guys
[Music]
foreign
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day of events of Revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and for any of you that
tuned in along the way as you can tell
this is a live International interactive
Bible study we are not only playing on
radio about 300 radio stations around
the country on satellite radio of Cirrus
XM we're on uh amazing facts Television
right now and we're rebroadcast on
several other television stations want
to say hi to friends that are watching
on lifestyle TV in Sweden hope Channel
and others and a better life good news
and thank you so much for tuning in
we're streaming on Amazing Facts
Facebook page the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page and you can send a text to
your friends right now if they want to
take in the second half of the program
uh my name is Doug Batchelor and I'm
Pastor Cruz and we're glad that you have
joined us for this evening's uh show and
we've got another caller uh with another
question we have Brittany here calling
in from our very own state California
welcome Brittany what is your question
Kim my question
is all the problems of the world we have
today
does it in does all this involve the
sign of the times mentioned in Matthew
24 and revelation 13.
okay good question now Matthew 24 well
there are three or four places in the
New Testament where Jesus kind of
highlights signs of his return you've
got Matthew 24 Mark 13 Luke 17 and Luke
21. there's nothing specifically in John
but twice in Luke
and uh
then when you say Revelation 13 that's a
little more specific when you're talking
about the Beast and the mark of the
beast though some of that has already
been fulfilled in history and I I tell
people if you want at the end of the
response here you can also request the
lesson on you know who is the Antichrist
and you'll see how that prophecy has
already been fulfilled but as far as
signs you know Pastor Cruz I did a an
online Bible Study last week that was
translated in Chinese it was a live
studying there was about over 200 000
people tuned into the stream and the
subject was seven signs of Christ's
return in fact I'll be in Australia next
week and I'll be also presenting that
study and I was going through just
things like conditions in the world
today with everything from
overpopulation to uh you know the threat
of wars and rumors of wars and Jesus
said in Matthew 24 there will be plagues
I think you know most people would agree
the pandemic was in that category though
not as bad as the Spanish Flu it was
still a deadly plague and uh
but there's always been Wars there's
always been plagues the things that make
it different today in my mind a couple
of things one is and Daniel chapter 12
and Jesus said many will run to and fro
and knowledge will increase
well you look at the explosive increase
in knowledge in the last hundred years
and Technology wisdom has not increased
but knowledge has certainly increased
and just everything is kind of going
robotic with artificial intelligence
and all my life people have accused me
of having artificial intelligence
this is a new new meeting now uh and
then you also have something different
it says the gospel will be preached this
is Matthew 24 14. the gospel will be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto the Nations and then the end will
come and now through things like this
program that's going out on the internet
around the world
and radio and television and the printed
page and missionaries and there's so
many means right now to rapidly
communicate with the world doesn't say
everyone would believe and be converted
it says as a witness
and the gospel is going around the world
I think in this generation so I don't
worry about the second coming I'm
actually very excited about it because
if you're ready
then it's a glorious appearing you're
looking forward to it but yes I do think
we are living in the last days no man
knows a day in the hour
I mean during World War II they thought
this is the end of the world with a
nuclear bomb
and here we are 70 years later
so but you look at the explosion of the
population around the world and the
resources that are being
consumed so it exponentially
quicker I guess it says the same thing
you wonder how much longer can it last
yeah and a a key verse is Matthew 24
verse 8. Jesus says all of these signs
that you're seeing in the world are like
birth pains some translations will say
sorrows in the original Greek it's birth
pains and the thing about birth pains is
is that birth pains get more frequent
and more intense the closer you get to
the delivery of the child right so Wars
rumors of wars pestilence right covid-19
Global pandemic all of these various
signs are going to get more frequent and
more intense the closer we're getting
and that's exactly what we're seeing
around the world today yeah even with
the natural disasters insurance
companies say that it seems like the
intensity and frequency is increasing
and Jesus mentions earthquakes in
Matthew 24. thank you Brittany I hope we
do have a a study guide that talks about
the second coming of Jesus and we'll be
happy to send you a free copy of that
it's called the ultimate Deliverance
all right our next caller is Abigail
who's calling in from Florida Welcome to
Bible answers live Abigail what is your
question
Hi how are you pastors doing well you'll
want to turn your radio down in the
background you're going to be hearing uh
hearing us say everything twice
hi
about 1 Corinthians 11 2 through 12
which discusses head coverings okay I am
wondering what this portion means
exactly and if women are still supposed
to wear something that cover the head
while praying or prophesying today
yeah well this is a difficult verse in
that when you you read it uh it would
seem like it's saying well I guess that
women are not supposed to pray or teach
in public unless they have their head
covered and
um the question is since it's there's no
command anywhere
in the Old Testament
specifically saying this and because
Paul uses the word later in the chapter
he says we have no other custom
and so many have thought well this was a
custom of respect by the way that's
verse 16. if anyone seems to be
contentious we have no such custom nor
do the Churches of God
is this a Bible mandate uh it's
understood that as a term of sub of
respect and or submission to their
husbands women were to cover their heads
in public I know Pastor Cruz when I
travel to
Europe and even some places in India the
women over we've covered their heads I
remember here in North America I went to
visit with uh give a Bible study to an
Apostolic Pentecostal lady and at the
end when we knelt the prey she looked
very nervous
because she had nothing on her head and
she grabbed the curtains
and she was by a curtain she grabbed the
curtains and put it over her head
because she was very sensitive about
praying in public not having her head
covered and that always struck me and I
thought well you know I have no problem
do you see the Mennonites the ladies
often have their hits covered
someone wants to do this but I don't
think we can make a command out of it
because the Bible says in the mouth of
two or three Witnesses you've got this
one verse where wondering is this a
custom if it was a command you'd see
some other corroborating evidence
somewhere else I think yeah good answer
good question and uh we'll keep
exploring you keep exploring our next
thanks Abigail
our next caller is calling in from New
York we have Frank on the line hello
Frank
yes
I have a question that you know I've
gotten a little bit of trouble with this
but nevertheless I've managed to tackle
it to the best of my abilities I read in
the Bible that it's an Abomination to um
look into the occult and to do things
that are against the will of God in the
sense of godliness and uh my question is
is it a a sin in itself
research
devil worship and and sorcery is there a
scripture in the Bible that says that
it's better to just be a Christian
follow God's principles and God's laws
rather than uh you know in dwell and
Ponder upon what devil worship is well
there are there are that's a great
question you know suppose you want to
research what devil worship is so that
you can expose it and preach against it
if you're researching it because you're
intrigued and interested that would be
very dangerous I think I would recommend
that most people unless they have a
special calling from God because they're
encountering something they do more
deeper study but I heard about a pastor
once that he was on a commission on
pornography in Washington and he thought
to better understand what he's going to
be addressing in the commission he
needed to research pornography in the
process of researching it he became
addicted to pornography so uh I would
say I stay away from the unfruitful
works of darkness as Paul says in
Ephesians
and just avoid these things you know God
says there shall not be found among you
anyone that consults the dead or a
soothsayer or a wizard or a witch
and uh you become like what you look at
so I'd say keep your eyes fixed on Jesus
yeah and uh the verse you just
referenced is Deuteronomy chapter 18
verses 10 through 12. and then maybe
this is a verse that will find itself to
be helpful uh it's in the New Testament
Ephesians chapter 5 verses 11 through 13
says have no fellowship with the
unfruitful works of darkness but rather
expose them the question is how do we
expose them well Paul says for it is
shameful even to speak of those things
which are done by them in secret but all
things that are exposed are made
manifest by the light for wherever uh
for whatever makes manifest is light so
the way in which we should expose the
darkness isn't by joining the darkness
isn't by trying you know digging
ourselves deep into all the things that
Satan is doing but rather proclaiming
the light from God's word right right
amen that's uh that's the answer thank
you you Frank I hope that helps a little
bit and of course you know amazing facts
has a lesson called does God Inspire
astrologers and psychics does God
Inspire astrologers and psychics if
you'd like a free copy of that you can
either call
800-835-6747 or what else can they do if
you have a cell phone you can dial
pound250 pound 250 and ask uh for that
resource yeah because I think you just
say Bible answers
all right who's next all right our next
caller is Steve calling in from Texas
and looks like you're a first-time
caller Steve Welcome to our program
well thank you greetings from Texas amen
uh I was I was curious
about uh who was running uh the store in
heaven when uh Jesus was down here on
Earth uh was there any Priestly duties
going on and who was doing that okay
that's a good question so when you think
about Christ as our high priest the
Bible tells us that in Hebrews and what
a priest typically does is he is
offering blood and sacrifice he's you
know pleading the blood of the sacrifice
and he's a mediator for the people well
Christ has always been our mediator but
it wasn't until the sacrifice of Jesus
that he went before the father pleading
his blood up until then there was the
ceremonial system and the temple on
earth and the sacrifices on Earth that
prefigured what Jesus would ultimately
do so when we talk about the Temple of
Heaven you keep two things in mind
you've got the dwelling place of God
where you've got the Throne of God in
heaven and he God's always been on his
throne but then as far as the Priestly
Ministry which is unique to sin Jesus
did not really activate that until after
his sacrifice yeah
so we have a study guide Steve that
talks about
the temple in heaven and it's called God
drew the plan and we will send you a
free copy if you'd like it's called God
drew the plan how do they get that they
can get that by calling in to
1-800-835-6747 and saying Bible answers
live or if you have a cell phone just
dial pound 250 and say Bible answers
live amen all right our next caller uh
we have here calling in from Illinois
and his name is Larry Larry my father's
name is Larry so it's a it's a great
name to have welcome to the show
welcome thank you uh Pastor can you hear
me yes we hear you loud and clear okay
okay so here it is I got a friend 30
years ago my friend and I were baptized
together in the remnant church and we
keep the Ten Commandments the seven-day
Sabbath and the faith of Jesus so my
question is now
for my friend because I was concerned
about him for five years he has no
Worship in a church in the denomination
he gives no tie
and uh I see him now and then is did he
lose the Salvation in the remnant church
and that's sort of my question and how
do I help him okay well the the yeah
important part of that question is can a
person who once fellowshipped can they
slip away and the answer is clearly yes
uh you know Paul makes it very clear he
says I could preach to others and myself
be a Castaway you've got examples in the
Bible of people who uh Hebrews chapter
six you know they walked with the Lord
but uh they they turned away and it says
it's impossible to renew them to
repentance now that would be a unique
case but they clearly they've turned
away in Revelation it says repent or
I'll take your Candlestick out of its
place and he's speaking to the churches
so how do you reach a friend or a loved
one that is drifting there's typically
four things you can do one is be a good
witness to them to pray for them amen
three if they're open and this is where
it gets a little delicate share
information you can't you know force a
person to listen to if you're preaching
to your kids and others all the time
you're just going to drive them away but
if they're open give them a DVD or
magazine or share with them or a Bible
study
give them a website to look at and so
they can read on their own and then the
the fourth thing is do the first three
patiently don't give up amen keep doing
the first three amen there's only those
really nothing else you can do be a good
Witness
pray and pray it's very powerful and
share information
and continue and persist amen yeah um
King Solomon was clearly with the Lord
for much of his life but then
um I was was mentioned a little bit
earlier in our show at the beginning is
this brother definitely backslid and he
in the Book of Ecclesiastes he describes
his life where he just went full on
worldly but he still came back to the
Lord amen right so you can be with the
Lord leave him but then still come back
so continue to pray for your for your
friend your brother in Christ and um
yeah just persevere in those prayers
amen well Larry thanks so much for
calling our next caller is Lee calling
in from Texas Lee welcome to Bible
answers live
what's your question thank you
yes my question is after the seven last
plagues well people will still remain on
Earth until Christ appears or does he
appear immediately after the seven last
place or is there maybe like a few days
after the seven last plagues and then he
appears
well if Pastor Cruz may look this up for
me but uh the seventh plague is
synonymous and I think this is going to
be in Revelation 16 uh yeah
seventh plague is synonymous with the
second coming
so that great earthquake and the hail
that falls from heaven
this is the coming of the Lord and so at
the conclusion of the seventh plague
it's a plague for the loss but it's
really salvation for the saved keep in
mind when the tenth plague fell upon the
Egyptians that tenth plague was the
harbinger that Israel was going to begin
its Journey the next day
and so uh it's interesting there were
ten plagues on Egypt the last seven
plagues God protected the children of
Israel and it was at the end of the last
seven plagues for the Israelites
that they were delivered in other words
the last seven that they were protected
from and uh it's at the end of the seven
plagues in Revelation yeah and uh that
seventh plague that you're referring to
is at the end of Revelation chapter 16.
the last few verses you can read that
and it's clearly the second coming of
Jesus
um is is strongly you know described
there yeah
thank you appreciate your question Lee
all right our next caller is calling in
from North Dakota and his name is Tom
hey Tom welcome to the show what's your
question thank you
yeah I understand regarding a
conversation with a friend regarding the
manner in which Jesus is coming the
second time and I've shared with him
first Thessalonians uh 16-17 uh about
him ascending to meet him in the Clouds
Of Heaven uh they had the question then
how do we reconcile uh Zechariah 14 1
through 5 where he is staying in
montevolves and his Switzerland 2 the
day of the Lord
so I I'm still not sure you the second
when it says in Zachariah that the feet
of the Lord touched the Mount of Olives
this is happening at the end of the 1000
years the second coming let me just say
okay yeah let me explain it and then I
think it'll become clear
Jesus went to heaven John 14. he said I
go to prepare a place for you and if I
go prepare a place for you I will come
again and receive you unto myself that
where I am you might be he comes he
takes us up we are caught up to meet him
in the air first Thessalonians 4. he
doesn't touch the ground at that point
we live and reign with Christ for a
thousand years but then you read in
Revelation chapter 21 he sees the New
Jerusalem coming down from God out of
Heaven the redeemed of course are with
him in the city
that's when his feet touch the Mount of
Olives creates a great valley the New
Jerusalem settles down into this
incredible Valley that's been created by
the Lord touching the Earth again
so hopefully that makes sense Tom and
and that also fits in with Zechariah
Chapter 14 where his feet touch at that
point his feet touched the Earth it's
interesting Pastor uh Aaron that
Jesus he said I'm going to come as I
left and it says he ascended from
Bethany on the Mount of Olives it's an
area right between the two and he's
coming back to the Mount of Olives so
he's literally coming back where he
ascended and his feet are going to touch
where they left it off probably yeah
yeah so to just summarize what you just
said Pastor Doug is that at the second
coming we know that he's not going to
touch her again but a thousand years
right after his second coming he'll come
a third time along with all of the
redeemed and that's when uh the new
Earth the New Jerusalem and his feet
will touch the Earth and that's when
that prophecy of Zechariah 14 will reach
a full fulfillment and then yeah the per
person may want to get our lesson on the
Millennium to really study that and it's
called a thousand years of Peace if
you'd like a free copy you can ask for
it right now
yep dial in pound 250 into your cell
phone and say Bible answers live all
right our next caller is calling in from
Florida and we have Carlos hi Carlos
welcome to the show good evening Pat
good evening passes yeah
yes my question is uh why were the Ten
Commandments put into the Ark of the
Covenant and the uh rest of the law
beside it what what did this mean what
was the purpose of that
well there's a distinction made between
the two
the the most holy object on the planet
was the Ten Commandments
what I mean by that is it was the word
of God and Jesus was the is the word of
God and it was written on rock and Jesus
is The Rock and in the holy city you've
got the holy mountain in the Holy Temple
on the Holy Mountain you've got the holy
Sanctuary you've got the holy place you
got the holy of holies and the only
thing in the holy of holies was a holy
Ark and in the Holy Ark you've got the
holy law
but the law of God was written with
God's finger the ceremonial laws were
written by the hand of Moses and it
mentions those again in Colossians
chapter 2. and Moses said they're going
to be there to be a witness against you
he's talking again about the ceremonial
laws they were put in a pocket on the
outside because they were of a passing
nature where the ark written by the hand
of God was a of an unchanging nature one
was the hand of man one was the Finger
of God one was written on Stone one was
written on parchment or we'd say paper
so there was a distinction between the
two one is permanent Eternal and one is
passing and but there was still a sacred
record for 2000 years
thank you Carlos appreciate that and
hope that we do have a lesson called God
through the plans and it talks about the
um the temple and the Ark in that lesson
yeah and just for the the other
listeners uh the the verse that Carlos
is referencing is Deuteronomy 31 verse
26. that's where it says the book of the
law shall be placed besides the ark
right while the Ten Commandments were
placed inside of it okay I think we've
got time for one more okay caller one
more question we have Barbara calling in
from Florida Welcome Barbara what is
your question this evening for us
hello
um my question is in Ezekiel 16
verses 10 to 13.
um basically it talks about jewelry
um expensive clothes so I was wondering
is it okay for us to wear jewelry and
expensive clothes since it says it's
okay in Ezekiel 16 Verse 10-13 okay in a
Jewish wedding uh the Dowry and the
wedding gifts were often given they had
no paper money they were often given in
the form of the Nice Clothing you'll
notice that Samson paid for his debt to
the Philistines with clothing
um and uh but if you read what it says
for example you have to compare
scripture with scripture to say well how
does God feel about uh jewelry go to
Isaiah chapter 3.
and if you look here let me see where
this begins okay we can say
yeah in that Day verse 18 the day of the
Lord he'll take away the finery the
daughters of Zion the Jingle the
jingling anklets the scarves the
crescents the pendants the bracelets the
veils the headdresses the leg ornaments
the headbands the perfume boxes the
charms and the Rings the nose Jewels the
festival apparel the mantles the outer
garments the purses so
describing one is a wedding picture of
God marrying the church but you also
have to look at where Paul says let not
the women be adorned with gold and
pearls and and Peter says let it not be
the outward adorning the wearing of gold
and that's in First Peter chapter three
uh we're running out of time I do have a
book that I've written on the subject of
Christians in adornment now there's
nothing wrong with wearing uh you know
quality clothing that won't wear out
Jesus had a nice robe that they didn't
want to tear up but as far as the
external frivolous adorning
um someone will write a song about
would Jesus wear a Rolex you know people
made fun of evangelists and people that
dress ostentatiously Christians should
be modest in their apparel is a
practical principle yeah so the book is
called jewelry how much is too much
jewelry how much is too much
call
800-835-6747 quickly for our friends
listening we sign off in two stages
we're going to say farewell to our
friends listening on satellite radio for
the rest of you we're coming back in
just a moment where the rapid fire Bible
questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
hello welcome back we have uh a few
minutes left here and we have some
questions that have been emailed to us
so Pastor Doug I'm gonna we're gonna try
to get through as many of these as we
can so our first question is this this
is by Ari from Norway InterContinental
here when Jesus was finished with his
mission on Earth did he then need his
own Redemptive services so to speak if
he happened to sin in heaven since he's
still a human in other words is it
possible could Jesus sin in heaven
well the Bible tells us that Jesus did
no sin Peter tells us that that he is
the sinless one and so Christ is the
only man that ever lived that never
sinned so he didn't need to have any
kind of redemption you know when he rose
from the dead he rose with a glorified
body
he's pure and perfect and uh
and if heaven forbid if he did need
Redemption his sacrifice on the cross
would have covered that but he didn't
yeah the last person to ever sin would
uh will be Jesus yeah next question uh
by Carlene she asked why wasn't Satan
destroyed at the flood and what is the
difference between not destroying him at
the flood but destroying him at the
second coming
yeah good question someone's thinking
well the whole world was destroyed and
Satan was outside the ark why wasn't he
destroyed well Paul tells us in
Ephesians 6 we don't wrestle against
flesh and blood you can't drown the
devil so to speak in water he's a spirit
and the reason he's destroyed is because
the fire when the Lord comes back is not
going to be a three-dimensional fire
it's going to be a fire that is going to
be the kind of fire that will also
devour Angels the Bible says that the
presence of the Lord is a consuming fire
and I don't understand the physics of it
all but God is going to send out
whatever nuclear spiritual fire it is
that the devil needs and his angels to
burn them up yeah and one more principle
real quick is in Matthew 13 Jesus tells
a parable about the wheat and the tares
and and Jesus says let bro let both grow
together until the Harvest there's
something about the full maturity of
both righteousness and wickedness before
God God brings a final end yeah and then
Matthew it tells us in Matthew chapter
25 31 it says like a fire prepared for
the devil and his angels Matthew 25
anyway yep yeah there it is oh hey
friends out of time send us more
questions next week God bless we look
forward to studying with you again next
week and go to amazingfacts.org
[Music]
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]